Robert Downey Jr was just snapped on the
set of his new HBO series The
sympathizer and it'll have you doing a
double take boy this is really kind of
cool yep that's Robert looking
completely unrecognizable on set in Los
Angeles sporting receding curly red hair
and bleached eyebrows while donning a
burgundy jacket and a pink shirt with a
white tee complete with navy pants and
brown shoes it's wild the fictional
drama slash Thriller follows a half
French half Vietnamese man played by HOA
swande who was a spy for Communist
forces during the Vietnam war Sandra Oh
also stars in the series which is based
on the 2015 book by the same name as for
Robert well he's playing multiple
supporting roles
start this project soon yeah yeah the
sympathizer I don't have to wear a ball
cap so when you guys shave my head that
was the actor back in October enlisting
the help of his kids to prep for the
role the a-lister who shares a 29 year
old son India with his ex-wife Deborah
Falconer as well as two kids
ten-year-old Exton and eight-year-old
Avery with his wife Susan Downey gave
his younger kids a razor and let them go
to town buzzing his head great job guys
I'll let you get back to your pumpkin
carving but what do I owe you money
Avery's got a better idea happy
Halloween
[Music]
I'm just pleased that it's entertaining
Robert captioned the clip quote the
things we do for our work and our kids
hashtag sympathizer set ready we just
have to sacrifice a few days later the
actor debuted his new do or lack thereof
on the red carpet at the premiere of
Netflix's documentary senior which tells
the life story of his late father
filmmaker Robert Downey Senior it's a
bit of a foray into trying to understand
your dad do you feel like you understand
him now I have a feeling I'll know a lot
more when we're done of course Robert's
newest project comes after playing Tony
Stark in the Iron Man franchise for over
a decade
Tony Stark just such an interesting
conflicted guy because he's a weapons
manufacturer but it's the relationships
really a bunch of my favorite actors
would come together to do this it's so
much fun back in 2019 Robert discussed
transitioning out of superhero life
after playing the pivotal role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe since its
Inception in 2008. I had incredible
10-year run that was
creatively satisfying was very very very
hard work and I dug very deep but I have
not been forced to explore the New
Frontier of of what is my creative and
personal life
after this well fast forward a few years
and it seems safe to say he's digging
deep into his new role and getting into
character all over again
[Music]